jean marc bonjour alors concrètement
qu'est ce que ça veut dire oui alors
vous avez raison c'est un peu technique
tout ça ça pouf d'ailleurs que christine
lagarde a tout compris du langage des
banques licences ubisoft trop on dit
toujours quelque chose à la banque
centrale en 10 des antilles les choses
avec un peu de watts pour que les pour
que ça paraisse pas trop mal finalement
aux banquiers de façon à ce qu'on les
comprenne très concrètement très
précisément elle vit la banque centrale
fait un énorme travail pour aider les
banques commerciales en france en italie
un peu partout en europe à rester en
équilibre pour aider les banques à
financer l'économie la banque centrale
distribuer des liquidités à toutes les
banques qui en ont besoin
la bce est d'ailleurs en limite de ses
compétences elle distribue des moyens
monétaires en contrepartie d'ailleurs
elle rachète des vieilles dettes ce qui
fait que les banques commerciales
doivent émettre des crédits tout neuf à
taux zéro si un peu de la planche à
billets tout ça qui ne dit pas son nom
elle fait un peu le jeu elle elle
fonctionne un peu comme un vide greniers
de toutes les banques commerciales et on
sait que la banque centrale est critiqué
pour cette générosité notamment par les
conservateurs allemands
les juristes allemands aussi qu'ils
considèrent que ça n'est pas dans ses
statuts que de faire autant de
générosité ceci dit c'est une politique
qui avait été initiée par mario draghi
et que christine lagarde a décidé de
poursuivre compte tenu des circonstances
alors ça que je le disais la banque
centrale européenne qui se dit déterminé
à participer au plan de financement au
plan de relance de l'europe
qu'en est il en réalité oui alors la bce
photo qu'avec cet argent les banquiers
fassent leur travail
distribuer des crédits or c'est bien que
cet argent tourne autour d'eux des
milieux financiers très souvent et que
la bce n'aimerais pas que cet argent
soit distribués aux banquiers et que les
banquiers s'en servent pour financer des
dividendes pour faire des profits ou
même pour verser des bonus à ses cadres
dirigeants dont mme christine lagarde ne
menace personne mais elle dit aux
présidents des banques et d'un messieurs
soyez sérieux sinon le système risque
d'exploser politiquement socialement
dans la situation actuelle du cercle
complètement indécent quand on voit la
situation notamment dans le secteur
ristic vous en montrer les détails il ya
un instant alors est ce que la banque
centrale être directement le plan de
relance européen
juridiquement non ses statuts je vous le
disais ne lui permettent pas les plans
de relance relève des politiques
budgétaires mais la bce elle fabrique de
la politique monétaire a directement
elle intervient donc puisqu'elle apporte
je répète aux banques de quoi faire des
crédits la bce va apporter au marché de
quoi souscrire des emprunts européens
christine lagarde a confirmé récemment
que la bce allait encore 10 tv pour plus
de 1500 milliards de liquidités soit le
double du plan de relance budgétaire
donc de l'argent il y en a alors est ce
que le système est solide et quels sont
les risques
oui écouter n'y a pas de risques
financiers
à très court terme aujourd'hui comme il
avait pu en avoir
en 2008 ou 2010 la dette ne coûte pas
cher 0% et l'économie n'utilise pas
d'ailleurs tout l'argent que le système
a mobilisé dans tous les pays de l'union
européenne
il ya beaucoup d' épargne de précaution
il ya beaucoup de prêts garantis qui ne
sont pas utilisés par les entreprises
d'où la tentation d'ailleurs des banques
et de distribuer des dividendes ce qui
nous règlerait absolument pas le
problème le problème c'est un problème
de confiance
les consommateurs ont d épargne de
précaution qu'ils n'utilisent pas pour
consommer suffisamment et les chefs
d'entreprise n'ont pas confiance dans
l'avenir tout qu'on a un problème de gel
de l'activité
un problème de choix on le voit bien
dans l'industrie du tourisme qui est
complètement dévastée donc à moyen terme
il peut y avoir une crise financière si
l'activité ne redémarre pas et il ya des
cendres le saura en fin d'année tout est
suspendu en fait à ce petit virus qui a
sauvé la panique et qui continue
d'ailleurs de semelles en bois sur la
planète toute entière et notamment en
europe aujourd'hui tout est suspendu à
la découverte du vaccin
merci à vous jean marc sylvestre âge
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialiste
économique sur arte france notamment
merci à vous